okay hello everyone
we are back for another 13.1 wilson
language design review
looking at
well trees geography astronomy
all right let's start with trees
oh this looks like a long review a week
it is it's a multi it's most likely a it
is multi multi meeting review okay all
right fine
uh okay is this is the end going to
speak to the trees
stuff
sure so the primary new thing in
thirteen one is that we now have the
full design of tree implemented and
consequently
we can import
all kinds of things like xml and
notebook uh faithfully into trees
do you have an example of that
um if you look at the documentation for
expression tree
what we hope to get
is more processing of those
yeah i'm sorry can you update your
documentation i should have reminded you
yeah okay
uh
this is crazy the way this works this is
just freaking crazy
sorry i'm just still
same mistake as multiple times before
okay
okay there we go all right so um can you
drag it over to the screen or which
i thought you were open oh i'm just
doing documentation update oh okay okay
um
okay
but let's get some scope here i mean a
lot of the stuff we've we've already
reviewed in some detailed trees meetings
correct
um yes so the
expression tree stuff we've discussed a
little bit
okay so there's a bunch of new stuff
i i would like to get scope for
everything we're talking about here
rather than
let's not drill too deep on trees right
now because we've had several meetings i
mean
we we need to look at these but i'm not
i just want to make sure we don't end
this meeting without having looked at a
little bit of things like astronomy that
we haven't looked at at all
okay so where's
xml tree
what the heck is that creature
so this is
the beginning of an xml symbolic tree
yeah well so this supports all symbolic
xml expressions
okay but if i were to say import and i
were to say comma tree in the importer
is there an import element for tree yet
or not not yet
okay why do we think that this is the
right way to represent this as a tree
so at each node in the document you have
tags that can have attributes
i understand that claim i mean so is
this is that kind of you know when we
think about an xml document
i mean this notion of tag and
the list of tag and attribute list
i think it's roughly right but i i would
like to sort of defer
until we see some processing of it too
because
if if it's not easy to process you know
i'm not then i'm not sure it's the right
representation and i mean you know xml
element is the kind of thing what might
happen at that node as well
rather than this list
because what you've done is you've taken
out xml element and you've turned it
into a list
well i've taken the first two elements
of the xml element and use that as the
data and then the the list of sub
elements gets turned into trees
i understand i understand but what what
what's happening there is a little weird
because what it really is
is this is the node well
see this is a weird thing this attribute
of the node is a different kind of
concept than we've had for trees
elsewhere
well right it's really just two pieces
of data
i know i know i know but it's it's two
pieces of data with a different
you know of a different character
because at some level when you read the
xml it's tag tag tag tag tag
and then there is an attribute
but that is sort of a footnote to the
tag in a sense
whereas here it's being given very much
the same weight as the tag
this is perhaps a formatting
issue
um
well i don't know what it's like
so in in this version we also have lots
of like detailed control over all of the
options and so maybe
we could have a label function that
renders this as actual
xml strings
right look we're going to spend our
whole time on trees here i really want
to do trees but i really want to see
what else there is here can we can we go
because let's just let's let's keep
going whatever you feel like yeah
keep going on things that i think are
going to be easier
okay
that's just great there's nothing to
discuss here that's just great um
now i i'm assuming that you also managed
to get um
uh
let's see if i say date writing speed up
is a little more than 100 x that's what
we approximated it but now we have
measurements so but it's in that
it's not a oh wow that was nice and fast
there was no slowdown for formatting
those things yeah the type setting
should be faster as well um that one
wasn't a specific line item here but
it's something we
improved along the way
okay good stuff so is this done with the
compiler or how is this done
um right now it was done just through
streamlining the
the generation of date strings and the
way that they're stored inside the
uh type setting and within the data
object itself so we remember
certain elements and we can regenerate
them quickly
there is ground to be gained there we're
hoping to get date string parsing and
date string generation even faster in a
lot of places but it's faster than it
has been
great and and this is also effect
interpreter and things like that is that
correct yep
yeah there's a number of different
pipelines we've been we've added a
couple of things for a lot of common
cases
edge cases get complicated so we have
i don't think if it takes a little bit
extra to do julian dates and the you
know whatever yeah that's fine we want
to make sure that the the mainline date
functions are fast we've been trying to
streamline each element of each object
and then
arithmetic was the big thing
you know i i saw some horrible things
recently with with um
date histogram and its tick choices
which may or may not be related to
anything you're dealing with that was
not in 13 1 so just uh
i just somebody should look at date
histogram and its tick choices
because they seemed insane
got a note of that
okay
this is just showing the improvement you
know we're two orders of magnitude close
to three orders of magnitude for well
[Music]
okay
i gotta look at these because it's such
a good good thing well look at those all
those zeros wonderful
great this is like candy
yeah yeah yeah indeed right it's great
um
nobody ever complains when you make it
faster right
okay
new massive continuous versus discrete
date
okay so we discussed these options for a
while had we not yep yeah so we went
back and forth on the names um there's
documentation on both the date
difference and date plus ref pages that
break down what they are um we tried to
get some illustrations that also make it
a little more apparent
um
see i've now left roger's trick for
actually opening these pages it's really
good okay so uh
so
remember first the difference between
continuous and discrete arithmetics
which is
whether you want to add three months as
the quantity
of time or three calendar months
yes i understand so that's the first
difference and then when you are dealing
with date with discrete arithmetic we
have several cases because the important
thing is what happens when you end up
with a date that doesn't exist like the
30th of
of
right february like you are adding the
30th of of january plus a month
what's that okay and then you have to
decide what to do at the end and this is
what's good
the default is to roll backwards that's
what we've done traditionally is the
last existing date is what we go back to
so you add a month to the 30th of
january even when you're subtracting
even when you when you get a date plus
that's a negative offset yep yeah so it
rolls back to the uh prior one and one
of the things that was slightly
inconsistent is that our date
normalization so if you put february
30th inside date list that one rolled
over but arithmetic rolled backwards and
there was no method for rolling forward
so now we have the granularity control
how you want to handle those cases
good
and some of this is housekeeping we
fixed some precision handling and
absolute time we also
reworked the time zone handling code so
that
time zone specifications can be used
consistently through the language you
can give a location
to as a time zone anywhere and we'll
look up the time zone and keep track of
it you can set your dollar time zone to
a location and it will look up what it's
supposed to be
hey what are we doing with future dates
in the us and um i mean
i i didn't even follow the whole
politics of daylight saving yes so we're
hooked into the iana timezone database
that updates a couple of times a year
with the legislative schedules so once
it is fixed when the daylight savings
transition stops
uh we'll update accordingly
no but i mean if i ask about a time in
the future does it right now say the us
isn't going to have to i just haven't
followed whether it's fully ratified
that the us is not going to have
daylight savings time yeah it's it's not
completely ratified in the u.s there's
still that's fine it's likely going to
be this all right so we we don't we
don't you know this is a i'll enjoy
specialty of when do we actually decide
that it's over so to speak
and the answer is probably not yet
yeah
great stuff on dates by the way what is
the general dates roadmap at this point
i mean do we is there a lot more stuff
that we think we have to do or are we in
pretty good shape here
there are a handful of things we
definitely have we want to we're
keeping track of what rob is doing with
the generalized array framework um
so that we can do things like data rates
we can do
automatic on on big collections and
conversions efficiently
there's a
offshoot of data arithmetic
that deals with modding dates that we
want to look at but we want to get the
baseline for the current version of
arithmetic
down completely so there may be a few
new i think i think there's a bunch more
performance things also
we're trying to kind of work in pairs of
improved performance add new
functionality where it makes sense well
also the list plot being able to deal
with dates is a big thing and i wonder
whether that's really been worked
through
you know like this thing that i was
mentioning about date histogram giving
stupid you know results
i mean we look at that but
um
i mean just just for just so i mean
whatever i can let's take the one minute
to just see what i'm actually talking
about
uh let me just see
um
yeah to rogers point we want to make
everything faster we're reasonable a lot
of the dates code was written in top
level and not super efficient so we've
been migrating things
okay trying to optimize them as we go
by the way point for avery this the fact
that this formatting is like
neanderthal you know ancient and this
doesn't have its number and so on this
needs to be regenerated
okay i have that
okay so let's see if i say entity value
why doesn't that auto complete that also
should auto complete
i'll try talking with tony about that or
maybe well yeah that's entity value it's
just an entity value issue that isn't
should be in user assistance that's
probably for avery to report
um
oh gosh i have to look up properties
here
um
isn't it
that was nice that that came out
actually i'm curious now if i fall out
the whole thing is it going to be
i like our new
thing down here
not bad that wasn't bad that was 2500 of
these guys okay let's try date histogram
of this
well that worked fine
maybe it's maybe it's well
it's a little weird
no it didn't work so fine it's a little
weird
why did it pick those dates
guys
we can't answer that we you know
no i understand but i'm saying i
i don't know whether that's the date
framework or whether that's the plotting
code
because i think if i take this let me
show you something
if i said
well i wouldn't have picked 1730 i would
have picked 1700 1800 you know 17 i
don't know what i would have picked but
these are these are weird why is it in
in
blocks of 70
why are those differences 70 years
see what i'm saying it's not a very
natural
thing to plot so if i say date value
a percent 12 comma year for example and
i get out a bunch of years there and now
i say histogram
okay now i've got very reasonable
see
so i i think that's something related to
dates i don't think that's you know you
know what i'm saying yeah i think it's
something in the charting code i can
check with brett about it well but it's
it's the interaction of that with the
date specifically right yeah
okay
um
all right good
uh
okay let's keep going geography
okay
is that new geo intersecting queue so so
for example if i say
um um so it's sorry it so that's
tentative it it doesn't exist yet so
so yes we want to separate that part
from geo within queue
yes no we don't have it yet so geo
within queue right now has a fully
contained option
and the idea is to separate this part
so that within queue really means
uh
within exactly and intersecting is
overlapping
sounds good to me
yes but it's not finished yet so
another thing is that we have linked now
to this zio's library and this allows us
to do some new computations that we
didn't have access
before at least at the speed that we can
do it now
now
yes this is important uh we are about to
finish the
contract we had with um
digitalglobe so we are changing to
mapbox
which
will provide the new tiles
we haven't changed right now
uh no we are about to make that change
there in the next one or two weeks
okay
and now the other one i'm sorry i just
want to point out for everything
do you notice this is offset this look
look at that um that that control the
eiffel has dropped down
yep the orange equal and the yeah it's
not text in the box yeah
okay sorry keep going jose
yes so so we will have now map box uh
tiles and so the main change here is
that mapbox requires crates
being explicit in the map
so you'll deal with that exactly yeah
um
and um but there is one thing which is
that we can
send a paclet update to 1300 but not
before
i see
yeah so so users of previous versions
will have to update to get titles now
we should have a separate discussion
about that yep
so there are some minor updates in
geographics related to zooms and we will
start using drop shadows
but but the real big thing is switching
by default to vector graph yes how are
we doing on that
um it's not finished yet
um
our main problem is speedy uh still know
that
yeah
so geographics right now still
it's since it's not done now steven it
cannot happen for 13 months i know which
is sad yes but i mean the important
thing is also the styling of the layers
and things
yes
agreed
what is vector
labels yes that's what you want
so let's see so these will only show
the labels so this is a layer that only
contains the labels
and so why was that in my geo background
autocomplete that seems goofy no no no
some you can now add a list of geo of
vector backgrounds and so for example
you can have say
um i don't know
relief map and vector
but jose the complaint that i have is
what happens there that's wrong
i don't want to see vector labels the
disembodied labels in my basic
autocomplete
why not because it's not what i want i
want a vector map how do i get a vector
map
oh i i see i see um yes
vector classic of vector
i mean
you can click the arrows at the end and
you see i know but i don't want to have
to click the arrows at the end i don't
want vector
yeah i mean i don't know what
i mean i don't know what we want to pick
as the as the generic vector thing but
let's pick
you know a generic vector we should just
say vector map or something as the
generic if you get what i'm saying
and and put that in the autocomplete
boy this is not fast
are we going to be able to speed this up
or is this going to be that the vector
maps are
what the heck is going on here why is it
spinning
why was that spinning
there is a part that happens
the first time you use
well why is a style
now when i'm just trying to resize the
style this this image
well i think you chose a particularly
dense area so this map has
lots of primitives inside
but yeah it's i'm surprised that it is
that slow it's really slow but there is
another thing that we haven't you know
that i haven't seen the results but
we've talked a lot about this which it
sends a lot of
label sets that is not needed
that it doesn't use
yes that's true it's sending lots of
languages and things like that oh gosh
okay well so we got to optimize that
right but but the other point is
i thought we were going to have all
kinds of styling for all the different
types of objects that appear in these
maps so you can style them as you want
yes we are working on that we have a pr
in which we can specify
uh
i don't know of the order of more than
100 objects and give individual styles
for that classes of objects yep
okay
so this is another thing that we are
working
as we speak right now
and updating the gdal library which is a
library offering lots of new formats
and so we are about to
that's an
that's another thing that um
i don't have a page yet
so i assume we would talk about trees
and dates in this meeting oh i'm sorry
okay all right uh but no no it's totally
fine to to tell you what
yeah yeah so the idea of geoframe
is the idea of having a like a frame
exactly like a frame but rather than
having projected coordinates it would be
marking latitudes and longitude lines
and values i see so this is something
that many users complain about that they
have a map
and because for loud scales maps are
given in mercator coordinates what they
see in the maps in the in the frame is
are the mercator latitude for example
not the true latitude and they get
confused about that
so we need both frame and geoframe wait
so
you'll be a rectangular frame that is
the frame and a geo frame will be a
a curvy linear type thing curved thing
that represents the actual lines of
constant latitude and longitude is that
right
yes but not necessarily curvilinear if
you go to the previous map and you do
frame goes to true you will see the
problem
just add frame goes to true to that map
except i'm not going to do it with
vector because it just put me off doing
that okay okay unless it's going to be
unless it's going to be fast a second
time is it it is because it doesn't have
to download the tiles i mean it still
has to process the all the information
again but it doesn't have to download
the time so you don't see the the
blue window
okay all right so now you want me to say
what
just adding the input frame was to do
now the thing is that new york has a
latitude of about 40.
but by doing this you will see that new
york is falling at around mercator
latitude of 46 or something like that
40
44. so those numbers are not true
latitudes are mercator latitudes
what the heck does that mean i mean so
if i say new york
nyc oops nyc
and i say latitude of that
exactly it's 40. that's crazy
well
no no no
the map has to be in projected
coordinates because it's the only
coordinates in which did you have a true
cartesian grid
uniform grid etc
right so once we plot the map at the map
the flood map is always in cartesian in
in projected coordinates
but but i don't understand i mean this
for example draw dome up of the whole
world
okay do geographic world
frame goes to true
and by the way
we can compute in either the projected
coordinates around the
the ellipsoidal sort of coordinates no
all all doesn't work
it it's thinking the do the range goes
to all if you want
okay
it probably should work by the way the
thing i did
sorry and and i forgot do your
projection goes to mercator
because this one is showing correctly
latitudes because this is the
do demarcator second one
okay so you see how latitudes go beyond
150
so by default the mercator grid goes
minus 182 plus 180 and minus 180 to plus
180 in latitudes too in vertical
coordinates
and so in fact the pole is at infinite
mercury latitude yes
but that's not showing as that on this
picture exactly the traditional thing is
to cut the mercator map square and so
180 vertically and because there is
nothing beyond 85 degree if if you why
don't you click
click on the map click period
and move the mouse
there you see both
the
the latitude and the
and the x and y coordinates you see
yeah so what we want to see
is is the latitude
um i i don't understand why it
disappears when you start why does it
disappear it shouldn't
okay it wasn't happening before maybe
that's a bug
yep
that's new got it
okay so the x and y are the coordinates
with respect to this frame coordinate
system is that right exactly they're
they're they're the projected coordinate
system indeed
why is this ever useful
this system because imagine that that
now you want to draw a line there and
you want to draw a perfect square things
like that it's much easier to do in
projected coordinates than in
unprojected coordinates
so you need both no matter what you do
you need both and so that's why it's
useful to have both frame and your frame
if if i were to put in a polygon here
yep with or a line or something you were
telling me that my my line
a point let's say a point
that that point would refer to let's say
a hundred zero no zero hundred
that will be projected
exactly now if you do
geo point of view position now it will
understand that that's
a
a a projected point
an unprojected point of geoposition
point of view position exactly and do
write for example so don't do this
my gosh
so that's the way we
allow wait a minute wait wait wait the
other confusing thing is that the lat
long is such that this is essentially a
y-coordinate first exactly yep
so for the second one you cannot go
beyond 90. for the first one you can go
90. yeah by the way you should show an
example like this in documentation
we do have but still
examples of this type mixing both things
okay
but but users still get confused when
this they see these numbers
so okay so what's going to happen if you
have a geo frame as well as a frame
so the geo frame will go inside
the traditional thing is that the the
geoframe has the numbers inside the map
i see
i see so
i see oh very interesting do for example
your grid lines go to true
or automatic
so you see how they are
the grid lines are spaced uniformly in
latitudes but not in projected
coordinates
right because that's a geostar thing and
if i exactly
if i were to say grid lines do we
support that here we support them but
there is an issue here which is that
they appear behind the map they are
there but they are behind the map we
don't yet have a way of placing them in
the front
okay
okay i understand this makes sense
pretty confusing okay
yeah but it's it's it's a standard thing
in geo that you always have to worry
about two coordinate systems right okay
this is going to be yeah this is
obviously an important thing to have all
right let me just have a quick look at
astronomy just because unless you're
completely unready for this
well we have the main thing which is
astroposition there is a page for
astroposition and and our plan for this
release is to have this function which
is
um like the fundamental one
and it's a it's it's a lot more powerful
than geo position
i'm not saying astronomy dot i don't
sorry in
uh astral position
no not the guide no look for the page
astral position okay
so if you go
there and you can click that or there
which is much better than the apple
search
okay and that works too
okay so astroposition is modeled
completely on geoposition
and so the structure is the following so
the first thing is that
this is going to describe positions in
some sort of
solar system-centered
world
or universe
and so the idea is that
the first argument has a number of uh of
coordinates the second one is going to
describe what we call the frame and the
second the third one is the coordinate
system
so the difference between frame and
coordinate system is is exactly like day
two man projection
it's like physics and maths if you want
okay the second contains the physics the
third contains the math
fair enough
so okay so that this is
with respect to the galactic frame
exactly this is this is coordinate
system what's centered at the center of
the galaxy or what the galactic frame is
centered at the center of the solar
system and it's oriented towards the the
x-axis is oriented towards the center of
the galaxy
okay
so there are lots of of
kind of historical choices here and the
collection of frames is going to be
larger of the order of 20 or so
and all these frames are moving with
respect to each other
and some of them contain say
relativistic correction so that do not
for example you see this epoch
so those are the the moving frames so
you have to specify the orientation they
have weird names like this mimi means
mean equatorial mean equinox
okay
it's it's it's a standard for
astronomers but
certainly non-standard for for
users who don't know about this so so we
will support the standard names and some
sort of genetics
just just one question about about dates
and things yep you know
i want to see the rotation of the galaxy
can i have a date that's uh 100 million
years in the future or is that going to
blow our system up
i mean the dates framework supports 100
million that's not a problem now what we
don't have is a model of the rotation of
the galaxy here this
so how should i say
so we don't have
models of the of the universe so this
doesn't have some cosmology
but it has very precise models from nasa
of the solar system
okay
and so
we are using some nasa libraries which
allows us to get very precise
positions for all the planets and all
the moons of the planets
i see so if i so to find out the
position of
i mean so in principle what i will be
able to do is i will be able to say
uh
in the end there'll be an astro distance
that will say astro distance earth comma
mars
and that will compute the current
distance between earth and mars is that
correct
right yes
so
we will i mean these frames have
parameters like the projections have
parameters the frames have parameters
and you can specify the
things like um
things like
do i take into account the time that the
light spends from one to another
yeah things like that but so this this
function though
will just work presumably i mean i
understand there's a light travel time
issue here and things like this
yep and presumably there's a version of
this which is what the invariant i don't
even know i mean depends what you mean
by this right if you have a
it really depends what you mean by this
thing here
exactly exactly that's what i'm saying
so by these you are all you are
effectively implying only the center of
what you are looking at but you have to
specify also things like yeah do i take
into account
um
light uh
traveling do i take into account
deflection by the sun do i take it
across things now oh gosh that is crazy
right the the fact that the um
that the time
the simultaneity moment
exactly is affected by that yeah so the
now
we will not use full
general activity here so the standard
thing to do is to have an expansion
which is called post post newtonian
and everything is
prepared to handle the first order of
porsche newtonian expansions which is
already complicated
yeah
but that's what the international union
of astronomy
recommends at the moment and we use
exactly that model
okay
okay but okay so then this will so
what's cool here is that presumably if i
want to get
um you know if i say astro position and
presumably there's an astro there's the
analog of geogrid position
which would give me
four mars it will give me the actual xyz
coordinates or something
maybe i don't care about those not
really so the the model i'm proposing
here is to have a single function which
handles the three things so so recall
that
we in in geo we have geoposition which
handles the datum second argument and
the agreed position which handles the
projection in the second argument
but we needed an object that handled
the three of them
and that's geogrid position your grid
position has three arguments so in a
sense geogrid position is our full
general object
so
astroposition will have three arguments
and it can handle everything in the
third argument like even projections in
the third argument
that's the model i am proposing i see
because the third argument is your
coordinate system which could be a
projected coordinate system onto like
some some i mean i don't know what the
analog of mercator projection of the
celestial sphere is what is all that
stuff i don't even know what that is
it it can be done it can be done uh for
example uh astronomers use a lot the
more by the projection for for maps of
the galaxy
oh yeah i've seen those yeah like the
cosmic microwave background is always
plotted in one of those exactly that
that's yes for for maps of the whole
universe and the galaxy they use
frequently more by them and so we will
be able to say more by the in the third
argument
but this there's the default spherical
so the most standard coordinates are
always spherical coordinates
okay and if you don't say anything it's
using spherical now spherical have
different names in different
frames so for example you see in the in
the example on the left they are all
spherical but sometimes they are called
right ascension declination and
sometimes they are called galactic
longitude and galactic latitude
depending on the frame they have
traditional different names
okay another question
the by the way this
minus convention here is that really
right
do you have the separate minuses on all
the coordinates
that's what we currently we do with
quantity with mixed quantities so i'm
just following that but i i fully agree
with you the standard thing to do is to
have just one at the front we should
probably
fix that but i mean also my question
would be this hours minute seconds thing
what what capabilities do we have for
dealing with those
once you get one of these out
go ahead yeah
so
yes so those are quantities
those are quantity angles in in right
ascension
so i do for example some position
um
sorry what am i do
yes so do celestial system goes to
in here yes an option celestial system
goes to
um
equatorial
the default is horizon
so you see you get hours of right
ascension
again material it's a quantity object
what's that sidereal time
oh yes yes that's a very good
instead of some position i want i i want
to go more you know full galactic whoops
what is it called we don't have that one
yet at the moment celestial system is
some position which is a former function
we only have two okay
it could be generalized to any of our
frames indeed
right
is this uh sidereel time and sneak sauce
or solar time
so you see they are angles all these
things are angles it's just that the
tradition is to
express them
in
in units of
right distinction
i see
if you do
what would be can we do arithmetic with
these in a reasonable way so if that's
an angle
and if i say
sine or cosine or whatever minus 30
degrees
not that one quantity 30 angular degrees
it's a quantity right
i see
i see but we can perfectly well do a
sign of this yeah yeah absolutely it's
an angle
it's just that the tradition is to
express this as the sidereal time
of your
meridian
of your local media
right
okay well this is cool so we'll have a
proper review of this soon when you have
the
yes yeah i'm about to to push that i
think let's let's go back to the trees
um oh unless unless some no we oh i see
so what does astro observe
yes the observe is a function it's
essentially the function that you would
say
where do i observe this object from this
frame
so where is where is mars right now from
this place
right if you don't say anything you are
assuming
uh
your analog of geogrid
you know the geogrid position except
that it's projected onto
this you know some coordinate system of
the celestial sphere is that right
or not
well i mean the idea is how do i know
where somebody in mars would see jupiter
so abstract service is a function that
allows you to say observe from this
other place
not from my location
oh i see
i see so wait a minute so so
it says so astral position normally is
with respect to a frame
and that and so what you're saying is
it's a frame to frame thing that is
well that's not quite right either
in a sense after observe is a particular
case of astroposition if you specify
the object being observed and the second
argument is a frame the frame could
specify from where right the frame has
an origin
yes but astra observe is some sort of
syntactic sugar to just say
from where do i see this object and then
we will choose a good frame for you
what do you mean i mean okay look the
basic point is people are on the earth
and they're at some geo position on the
earth
so presumably
one of the things that
i mean there is a frame for astro
position that cares what your geo
position is
yes yes
and
you know in galactic coordinates doesn't
really matter what your geo position is
right
okay
but so
this is saying i the name astro observed
does not make it for me
i mean
so
this would return
like this is the analog of sun position
or something it's telling me from my
current location i mean i could say sun
position i don't even know if i can do
it can i say sun position from the moon
no right now
no okay fine but but astro observe
what will be the syntax to say where is
the sun and the martian sky
well it will be the first argument sign
the second you would specify allocation
in mars
and then it would return which function
sorry which function is this in a strap
serve
i see
or i mean in a position you can specify
a second argument a full frame
based on mars but you have to know so
the in a sense after observe
is some sort of
shortcut
but by default it will return
what um
you know altitude azimuth for
for my position on mars for the sun all
it will return right ascension
declination
um
well
there
it is some sort of automatic choice i i
don't think we should use exactly the
same choice everywhere because for
example imagine that you are sent
observing from the solar system body
center
imagine that you are observing from the
body center of of of jupiter
system so those places are points
perhaps in space
you see so you can observe from places
which are not associated to anybody to
any any physical body
and therefore and those places the only
reasonable coordinate system
is some
solar system coordinates not
exactly not not something where there's
a ground underneath you type
exactly yeah so there is some sort of
automatic choice of frame to be to be
made there
some convenient
how high do you have to be from the
earth but not to use the earth
in other words if i'm in you know
it's like the gps which which
you know conveniently switches from
daytime to nighttime mode when you go
over the
the terminator or whatever when you're
driving so to speak um
and this you know if you're if you if
you're in a a convenient you know if you
take
the system and you're you're in a rocket
there'll be some moment when it changes
from the coordinate system to the earth
right how far do you have to be if
you're in earth orbit is it going to use
a coordinate system where your feet are
planted on the ground or is it going to
use a coordinate system where you're
free floating in the solar system
um
well
i mean there are frames which rotate
with the earth and others that do not so
the standard thing when studying for
example satellites is to use those
frames that do not rotate with the earth
because if you add the rotation of the
earth and the orbit looks very strange
yes indeed right it'll help
okay but so but the point is what i'm
saying is as you continuously vary the
altitude above the earth there will come
a point when your auto selector will
change its default coordinate system
right yes which is definitely on the
weird side
yes it's a bit like when we change the
projections depending on the scale there
are some
some sums
yeah but that's
this is an actual result because i mean
this is going to return what is this
going to return it's going to return
what will this return and that's the
position object
i see so it's formatting can perfectly
well say what it is yeah absolutely yeah
yeah
and this your position objects will be
more complicated than sorry this
astroposition object will be more
complicated than the opposition
so so i'm planning to to format them
always
as you saw in the rough page rather than
in the position we only format the
multi-position cases right
okay so look astro observer let's just
think of a name here so what that is is
what is the astral position of one
object from another is that correct
yes in i would say the general case is a
it's a trajectory versus a point
right so the idea is that you say mars
it's not actually a point it's a
trajectory in in space-time right so you
give a an
an event uh uh
a position and a time and it will
kind of compute that the light ray that
intersects that
line and it gives you the intersection
point
yes
but
the simple-minded version of this is
what does thing x look like from place y
and the fact that it's doing that
in time
no but time is problem because of
because of simultaneity because there's
some athletic conventions in the fact
we've got light rays yeah but everything
is moving so when when is map mine
matters yeah i see i see i see exactly
it what we see is the direction of the
light ray as it reaches us
so not the actual position as it is
right now
um
i'm kind of thinking that some sort of
relative astro relative
um
okay it's going to return an astro
position
which is strange in its own right
because it is a
there is for the object that you're
looking at the sun let's say there is an
astral position for the sun
which is
in some coordinate system in some frame
et cetera et cetera et cetera
but now what you want to do is you're
returning a
a courtesy modified astro position that
has the right
is from the coordinate system
you know in other words it's the same
astro position
the sun is you know you could take the
asteroid position you get out from astro
observer whatever it is and you could
compute anything you want to know about
the position of the sun from that it's
just that its default
uh its default presentation
is as appropriate for mars as opposed to
as appropriate from the earth right yep
yep
so it's a way of changing the the origin
of the frame
if you want
right but it doesn't really affect the
position that is you can always
reconstruct the genuine position
of the sun because it astroposition
contains its frame information yes
so this is
when you say the sun the sun is not a
position sun is a line in space time
right it's a trajectory yeah so what we
are doing here is a computation of
where does the light come
from myself at this time intersect that
line
yes
but but is it returning but it is still
returning in astro position is it not
yes
which is
yeah which is some kind of tangent
object because
what it is is as you say
it is the
it is the local direction
of the light ray
where you are
as opposed to the originating
sort of space-time position of the sun
correct
yes it's where does the sun appear to be
at my position
yeah so it's kind of the it's a
it's really a little different than an
astral position it's really some kind of
tangential you know local astro position
is it not
i would say it's an astral position
expressed in in let's say [ __ ]
quartets
so
right so
given a point you have the past light
cone the
the the space like
plane
the simultaneity plane you talk about
and you have the future light column so
we could also have an abstract emit
eventually
so if i emit a light ray from now
where does it intersect
the the moon or mars
and that would be the future that would
be the reversed
i have this
um with observations we are always
looking at past likes
with emissions we will be dealing with
future light counts
this is very obscure i mean it the
concept is is clean
i just think the name is
is not
um
this says
where did it appear to be
where did this object where does this
where
to me here where does the object appear
to be so to speak
um
there's got to be a name for this in
astronomy isn't there
observation and the mission
but it's not
yeah it's apparent apparent position or
it's also called
maybe we should call it a parent astral
position
or astro apparent position
don't you think that that sounds obscure
a lot less obscure than astro observe
which i don't understand at all
astro observers like wheel out the
telescope as a as a um you know
but it's sort of what it is
it's not
it's a i mean if at best it's an
observation
it's not an observe would be a command
turn the time fine fine if it's
positioned then it's observation maybe
i don't think that's right though i
think astro observation sounds like i
took this plate on this night and i saw
a comet in it
yes but a parent is a weird name
it's not so weird in astronomy
you know there's plenty of apparent
magnitudes and all this kind of stuff
apparent is as it appears to me as
opposed to absolute magnitude or
whatever
i see
i think i was trying to avoid again
having a multiplicity of x position a
strokes position
but i mean in a sense we could even
avoid having a strap serve if we just
make astro position to do those changes
yeah to have a center
we we could
say overload the second argument of
astroposition to to do what astropsy
would do and just leave with a position
at this point i mean we could we could
have a thing we'd have an option to
astroposition called
um astrocenter or something like that or
astro origin
yes in fact the frames need to know
their origin of course frames need to
know
their origins their orientation and the
time system they are using as a clock
right but i mean
as
i said at the beginning astro upsell was
to me some sort of syntactic sugar for
astroposition no i understand that and
it's interesting for that but i mean
there's so like there's an astro
location
that is the analog of our geolocation
is there not
just like i can say geolocation and that
tells me where i am
i can reset
can't i
oh oh i see what you mean yes yes of
course we can take the information of
now and dollar your location and compute
a dollar astroposition for us to
location yes
yeah
is if we have that dollar astro position
which seems useful to have
then
we can use an astral position without a
dollar and reset that to be on mars for
example
yep so we could then have
you know astro
sorry what did i say i meant astral
location so it would be
astro position blah blah blah comma
astro location arrow such and such and i
can imagine when we have astro graphics
we can have something that says astro
location arrows such and such
i i see what you mean i wonder whether
we should simply allow dollar year
location to be anywhere
[Laughter]
i predict that's going to cause trouble
i mean do we think our algorithms for
projection
are capable of being at the galactic
center i really doubt it
in other words if you did that
think about all the singularities we get
in the um
yes yes yes you're right you're right
yeah
yeah many geo functions will be confused
indeed
right so i think it's better to have i
think it's cool to have an astro
position
um
you know
as as the world gets more space faring
um maybe that will get to be set you
know the question is when that first
gets set by default
on a computer
you know
not because it's clearly not going to
use in deep space for example it's
clearly not going to use ordinary gps
right could you set your astral location
to be the
iss
you should be able to
yeah i think so
right and then that way
right you can't set your geo location to
the iss
no
so i think the big difference between
astro and geo is that the time element
is there
so
you know in the case of geolocation
we're just ignoring relativistic effects
and it's just you are in a certain place
on the earth or on the moon or whatever
whereas
in the
astro position
i have to run i'm going to request one
more of these
okay
can we go on with trees for a bit
without you or is that yeah absolutely
no no problem go on
okay see you later see you
see you
all right
this is great all right let's go let's
try and dig a little bit into trees here
sorry i i was avoiding the trees
um in case there was a bird that was
gonna whatever
never mind
um
okay
so which of these things have we not
talked about
what's tree visualization
it's a new guide page you haven't seen
it's not a guide page it's a function
it's a guide page
well there is a function called
reversalization as well what the hell's
that
that is from
when trees were still
just working directly with data
structures
so you should probably remove this page
ah
okay
that's amusing is that real tree
structure
um it's in the trees context right now
and we're not proposing it for thirteen
one
tree outline is that real
yes
has that been there before it's been
there from the beginning
i've never seen it
well so
we didn't look closely at it for 12.3
and we've had a few meetings since then
uh with
noah for an updated ux and design for it
i don't think we should be talking about
this yet this is not ready
yeah
there's nothing new for free outline for
this version
but that's but is it on a guide page
yes
it's it's been on the main trees guide
page under the visualization section so
i also put it on this
i mean this is really
oh boy
we need to look at this some more
i'm i'm just very unconvinced about this
um
i think the idea of having something
like this is good it's just that the
visuals are not good enough
and no has much better suggestions
i see
do you remember a meeting with with john
fultz in which he was
proposing a tree view function
and he wanted to to connect both
projects and
yes
yes i do i do remember that but okay
hold on let's let's look at some of
these others okay so
okay what's really new here
so tree label style all the stuff
all of those options listed there are
new okay so so tell me something i want
to take this tree and i want to just
make dots for every node how do i do it
so you could already do that in 13 by
just saying all goes to none no no no no
that's a horrible solution is there a
better solution
horrible by what metric well i mean i
just don't think anybody will ever get
it i mean you say all arrow none no so
you so tree
element label
yeah that's pretty horrible
that's what i have to do
oops
and i don't think that's great either
because i don't want it to be that fuzz
you know that that light
see what i'm saying
so those are the same colors as
when you don't have like when you do
have labels no that's probably wrong
it's probably wrong they probably should
be darker colors in case we don't have
labels
okay that should be looked at
but i mean the basic point is i want
some way to show this like a graph
but it is in a tree structure you see
what i'm saying
and if i say
tree graph it's going to blow it up
am i making sense so are you wanting to
do like a shape
like different vertex shapes yeah i want
to draw this right so now so now we have
multiple new options for that so you can
do like tree element shape
or tree element shape function
and specify those
um
like change tree element label to
trigonometry function
[Music]
that's amusing but it's not what i
wanted
uh
let's go back to this question i just
want to make it
like look if i take this thing
and i say tree graph
okay that's a formal formatting i want
to get that formatting for the original
tree
because this i don't know is this the
same did this have the same coordinates
should
well that's okay i guess
so
the default shape function for
graph is is just called automatic and
i'm using automatic
for this for tree's default shape
function so i don't have a name for the
default shape function that graph uses
but you can use any
shape function the graph supports in
tree
well we needed
you know graph default or something
as a name but the thing that i'm
concerned about is okay so i want to
make some very big trees
okay so i want a really big tree i'm
going to make a really big tree
and i want to make it without all this
gunk in it okay
so i mean i just want an easy way
because you're thinking of trees where
everything is labeled but i'm thinking
of trees
as something where they are more kind of
mathematical structures so let's say
i've got a tree with a thousand elements
and i want
i mean this is pretty horrifying tree
element style arrow all arrow none
why is it so slow
oh for goodness sake what did this just
do
none is not a style
what the heck what am i supposed to do
here tree element what is red instead of
none
no i don't want to do that i want to
just have simple dots for every node how
do i achieve that that's a shape
function
that's not good enough it's too obscure
i mean the style is not going to control
the shape shape is going to control okay
i don't understand
for
okay for graphs we have this notion of
uh you know vertex labels
the the difference is that there is a
default appearance for a node in the
graph
and the label is then labeling the node
rather than being in the node
so to speak
so for tree element label option
okay tell me how to do what i want to do
here i just want a dot for every node
how do i do it
as i said we would need a named shape
function that matches the graph
but you could do for example the string
square and that'd be close
tree element
function
like this
like this
yes
it's really slow
why is it so slow
why is this so slow
should not be slow i mean this is the
default case for any big tree you do not
want to label the elements in the big
tree
okay what the heck happened here
what did this do see this is full of
garbage
well because labels are shown by default
okay but i'm telling you we need a way
to get something so you're just showing
the mathematical tree you want an option
that shows that controls both the label
that is correct i want a simple way to
get the look there that sounds like a
plot theme
well it's not going to be a kind of
thing there'll be some kind of option
that just switches off because i'm
telling you there are two uses of trees
i mean i've been using these trees
and they're very nice well done
but there are two uses
number one it's a tree where every node
has a meaning
right that's case number one that's the
case you've tackled case number two it
is a mathematical tree where i don't
care what the nodes are called
right and you're not handling that case
properly
so i'm saying that's the case which is
much more like this
i mean
i i don't agree with that like random
tree is a generator for
labeled trees it could there
there could just as well be a tree
distribution that generates
just pure trees like you're saying
and then you don't have this problem at
all because there's just no data there
but by default if you have data in the
tree it shows it by default
well fair enough that's a reasonable
argument but then random trees should
have a way and other tree generators
should have a way
to not generate added one to expression
tree for example
okay let me see
that so if i say
i mean okay but but here for random tree
how would i blow away let's look at
random tree for a second maybe there's
an easy way of changing random trees so
i can deal with this
so i think in in the first argument
where you can currently give an n
eventually you could give a symbolic
tree
distribution well we're not going to
that no no but this is a much simpler
case
this is a unlabeled tree it's a very
simple concept and this is what we want
i'm not even sure that the default is
right to give a tree with actual
explicit labels like this
but i kind of think it's wrong
well i think the idea of creating tree
was precisely to have the labels
in in
right
okay but i'm telling you we need a
notion of a tree in which there are not
labels most of the time
yeah so how do we get these are the
labels
i mean you can map
a constant function null here
and you'll get the same thing like if
you have tree with one argument then
there's no data
we specifically made the we specifically
made the data optional so that it was
easy okay so then then let's say if i
say here tree map
of none
is that right
null ampersand
okay
apart from the fact that this is too
light this is a good result well and
these things are too big
so if i say tree element size
i i think that the
that needs to work
yes
why didn't that work
oh um tree map doesn't take tree options
why not
only things that construct trees
currently take tree options
doesn't it construct a tree
why doesn't tree take no i mean things
like random tree nest tree expression
why doesn't tree take a tree option
tree does
why doesn't this work why is it really
wrong
tree tree element size
oh well
there's
i think the page is the documentation is
not okay
in the build yet
okay but so here that doesn't seem right
it's not doesn't seem to be working
right so the size isn't working with the
um
default shape currently but if you
specify a different shape that's right
so it needs to work
and i'm not convinced that these default
shapes are right i think they should be
smaller and i think they should be more
like this
you just don't want to see i mean you
know you just want to see the structure
of the tree you can see you don't need
to see this this very
you know precious squares and circles
type thing
so this is the point that i want to get
across so then if you have removed all
the labels these nodes would be smaller
and
i did remove the labels
yeah i'm saying your suggestion is to
have smaller yes that's what i'm
suggesting i i think the thing you have
to think about is
there are mathematical trees where you
never care what nodes are labeled
so what i'm saying
i'm going to compute properties of these
trees and so on but i never care what
they're labeled
so we need to support that well
and i think what we need to do is to
have a random tree
do something like
you know if we say something like
uh
i don't know whether the right thing is
is arrow none or something i i don't
really like that very much
how do we get something which says i
mean i personally think the default from
random tree may be incorrect you can say
tree element label arrow no no no no no
no
none of those things this is a very
basic case
right this is a mathematical tree where
nobody cares about the labels and we're
not going to do any three element label
nonsense
you want a special syntax in the first
argument for the
probably it's in the first argument i'm
not certain where it should be but but
i'm saying we need something which says
this is a mathematical tree it doesn't
have any labels it's just a structure
and my point is that we'll have a
different uh
distribution than
the labeled one wow just an additional
trade what what why
why because if it's not labeled then you
can only distinguish two trees by their
shape but if they are labeled you can
distinguish them by their labels as well
okay i understand that claim i think
this requires a bit more thought
but i'm saying for goodness sake let's
figure out how we support well pure
mathematical trees
and don't tell me to set seven options
with lots of weird fiddly stuff in them
because it's not what people are gonna
want you wanna look at expression tree
yes
the source documentation
right so there's this new structure
if you do the if you say null in the
second argument then it just gives you
an unlabeled tree
so that's a different i see that's null
so name aside
we just added that as an additional
structure so you can just directly get
them yeah okay so what you're saying is
if we say you know some random thing
um
and then we say expression tree
yep that's nice
that's what i wanted except that i don't
like these shapes here
you know this this should be darker it's
really just way too ethereal
makes sense
but the functionality is good this is
exactly what i wanted
yep and and also expression tree now has
the heads option
good
this is good this is nice this is very
useful
um
all right let's just fix the what what
it does by default when it formats with
everything as
it's going to require a little bit of
cleverness with graphic design because
if
some of the nodes are blank but others
are not this is not an unreasonable way
to do it probably but if they're all
blank i'm a little confused what to do
here
you see what i'm saying
yeah we might need a compromise that
just works in both cases
probably yes which i think the
compromise that will work is to darken
the node and have it be smaller
and that will look okay in both cases
okay so then maybe what we want to do
you know another possibility like we've
done with graphs or we have directed
graph undirected graph maybe we want to
have a thing called unlabeled tree
or something you just wrap around a tree
and let's go boom and blow all that
stuff away
and that would be a perfectly fine
solution as far as i'm concerned
is this a converter or a container
converter
just like you know
uh undirected graph as a converter
yeah
i think that's a good solution
yep
and that way we can
you know now you're right that we can be
fancier with the distribution of random
tree and so on but we can still say
unlabeled tree
um
maybe unlabeled tree can set some
options
in terms of yes when it yes absolutely
it can set some options on the tree that
it has been fed
that would be useful for it to do but at
the very least it should just go through
and do the do this effectively tree map
of now blah blah blah
that will solve that that
that will solve the most basic version
of that problem i think
now um
it's getting you know the whimsy is just
catching up on us tree leaf
count you know whatever
it does count the actual leaves the
things at the end right yes
it's the analog of leaf count
okay
so this is what we discussed before like
root tree and so on which i think is
good
um
question the um okay let's take a look a
little look at tree expression
expression tree for these cases
okay so
your
i should probably save this file as well
um
uh
what should i be saving this under trees
bro what should i be saving this
under you can save it under the trees
folder
okay
okay so let's let's take this
and okay so
you're telling me i can do look at all
these cool things
okay so for example i could take this
notebook
and i could say
um how do i get this notebook i say get
notebook get right notebook
or
not forget of evaluation notebook
okay so now i say expression tree of
that is that correct
comma
the string notebook
uh hello computer
what just happened
oh my gosh something's spinning still
is this going to re-render the notebook
within the notebook within the notebook
and some kind of dust effect thing no it
doesn't try to render the notebook but
it's going to try to display a tree that
shows all the
boxes
in standard form
i mean that's standard form you mean you
mean it's it's going to display
okay so this is pretty dead in the water
here i don't know what the data of the
leaves is like the raw like the boxes at
the bottom of the notebook
okay so geographic's gonna mess that up
oh
yeah it's got all kinds of weird stuff
in it hasn't it but but now what we're
probably going to want we may have to
kill this but what we're probably going
to want here is notebook cells notebook
you know what i'm saying because you
don't want in many cases you don't want
to go below the cell level yeah so the
hierarchy that this currently handles
goes
notebook then cell then cell group and
then everything below that is a leaf
oh okay so this won't actually dive into
so i don't understand why it's spinning
like this
it's not going to dive right into the
expressions on the on in the cells right
so why is it spinning it's just a bug
up nope
that was just completely dead in the
water
okay let me let me just start a notebook
and just do a trivial thing in it um
okay what the heck is that that is a
completely unuseful object
what is that i the same comment i had
about xml holds for this i think we need
formatting functions to format the
payloads better yeah but this is also
going below the cells it's wrong it
shouldn't be doing that it's not
it is look at that it's got box stator
in the leaves that's below the cells the
cell
that's what what i said is the hierarchy
goes notebook then cell then cell group
and then everything below that is a leaf
okay so it probably should stop at the
cells or at least there should be a way
of telling it to stop at the cells well
so this is just when you're only going
to have a tree with one level of
hierarchy that's not true you can have
cell groups
i i don't know what you're you so are
you saying that the data of the cell
should be in the parent rather than
there being an additional leaf yes
yes because what you want to see is the
cell group structure
that's the main thing you want to see in
a case like this
so
okay so the way i'm doing this now can
handles all cell expressions exactly the
same way but this would be
special handling for the cells
immediately above how do i get this to
make this thing have um no labels
tree element label
no no no no no no no no no i want it at
this level see this is the point you're
not understanding i'm sorry the the most
of the time when i use trees i don't
want
you apply unlabeled tree to this okay
all right fine
i'm not
okay fine
you just you don't even want to generate
these i mean these labels are just a
mess
okay so tree element label arrow all
arrow none is that right
okay so what i want to see
is
the hierarchy of section headings and so
on that's what's really useful to see
anything below that but the level of
boxes is almost certainly not useful
okay this is an outline that is very
useful but only at that level
and i would predict that 90 of the time
i'm gonna wanted something like this
possibly with some tool tips
so so this currently doesn't try to like
understand things like sections and
subsections is that what you're wanting
it does need that it needs to understand
the cell grouping that's it that's all
it is this just blows out all of the
cells and cell groups into subtrees is
what it currently does
it sounds like you're wanting something
i want the cell grouping
i want the cell grouping to be
illustrated in the tree that's the point
but i have a sectional group data nodes
here
right and they're hierarchical aren't
they
so i mean if i were to put a section
heading in here
and run this again
i think that did what i wanted except it
went too deep
i don't know did that do what i wanted
okay so it's got the first cell
okay so the first cell here apart from
the fact that i've got those little
tentacles hanging off
i don't even know what that oh i see
that's the cell group
no i don't understand this what's that
node
be easier with the labels
haha
i don't understand what oh
of
well actually that's too complicated
no but but look look i don't know what
that note is it should be there should
be a i need to think through this but i
there needs to be an easy way to make
this show up in tool tips
yes
i mean if i just if i even say head here
how do i get the head of that
so i say all arrow can i
do
uh and and do head why can't i do this x
blank colon equals head of x because x
is a position
can i do it with a hash something or
other
no
okay so what do i want to do the element
label function
goes to all goes to head
that's extremely unuseful well let's say
all goes to
what do i want to say hash sub 2 comma 1
no hash sub head of hash sub 2.
oh i don't understand what this is doing
i don't know who all goes to first
well
so because this went too deep you get
garbage at the bottom but
this is this will just show you the
symbols for notebook and cell
cell group
how do i get to not go so deep
with expression tree is there a way of
saying of giving a level spec in the
expression tree
not yet
should be probably
uh
can i do this with root tree
how would i how would i reject the
degree of that
well how many how many levels of root
tree do i want to do try two
uh
something went wrong
okay this is still very messy
right and and so
okay so look i think just to talk
roughly about what these things should
do i mean notebook in my opinion the
number one useful thing is um
well okay
actually
do you have
text structure now as trees
yeah you can give that as a second
argument in expression tree
but it won't do the pars it'll do
i don't know oh no no no no it's not
hooked up to text structure itself but
you can convert the output of text
structure
into a tree using expression tree
okay so now expression tree
of that comma text structure right
or text element
you know i am happy to say that even
though i am slouching i can read the um
the input output labels so that's a
that's an achievement
because of course it really is a sign
don't slouch
um
that is very ugly
we're not quite there with this i mean
maybe it's a labeling issue i think so
for all of these i just
took
all of this the data that's in the
expression and just dumped it into the
data fair enough
yeah i mean in this case right with the
right labeling of clause and so on that
that would look pretty good i mean if
you if we mimic this effectively i mean
in this case here
we've got
um
oops constituent graph rather
confusingly is different and by the way
okay so that's sort of the thing i don't
know why that's that's darker color i'm
surprised by that but that's kind of the
thing we're going for for the tree i
would say
although that particular thing really is
a graph but we should have a tree
version of this and i mean that's what's
really confusing because we've got the
construction
the constituent tree returns a text
element
right so we're going to have to come up
with another name for what text
structure
to make it return an actual tree
and we may be able to mess with the word
constituent
um
forestry or something i'm not sure
but i mean i think this is roughly what
we're going for in terms of the the the
look of the default expression tree from
this
um
yeah the nice thing with both of these
like all of the options and expression
tree is that we could
have expression tree produce things with
all of the proper options
yes i understand and preserve the
options while you're doing operations
with them
that's good and that happens most of the
time most operations you do will
preserve the options
because it's just treated tree
transformations right it's not like i
mean in the case of let me ask this
question so in the case of graphs we
have many things like craft union and so
on
we don't have a tree gluing thing yet do
we
a white
tree gluing that is you attach a tree
you say i want this subtree at this
position
i think that's tree insert
okay then explain to me how the options
work with tree insert
so
i have an input whatever is that i
haven't committed it yet but you insert
a tree with some options into some other
tree with some options and the way we
set up the options is that they are
inherited
um
if you don't specify options you you
take the options that are specified by
your parent i see they apparently know
and so so it's like a waterfall
cascading down the tree if the root node
of the subtree
is red
then all the sub
well so if you just say red then only
the root will be red but if you say all
goes to red then everything will be red
and subtree can still override that
right so all is blue at the top and then
all is red of the sub tree you inserted
and that's blue for a while and then
it's red in the sub trees exactly yep
yeah that makes sense
um
okay we should probably wrap here but
but uh i mean this looks close honestly
except for things that i mean i you know
we clearly need to go through maybe you
need to do another iteration for a few
days on these other things here
and see if you can at least get them
halfway reasonable
that makes sense and then uh
oh you really are you putting in the one
for trace that's cool if you can do that
um
and i'll put trace tree and trace graph
in the wfr
fine
fine that would be cool i mean that that
stuff was going very well if you can if
you can figure out how to merge it with
what nick is doing i think we're really
going to have a great setup there
have you been interacting and think
about that stuff at all
um not on that we're meeting tomorrow to
discuss the pure math package
okay
which is about i see that was
that connects to
uh jonathan's ct framework but also nyx
multi stuff and
we also have tony and michael there for
sparkle
cool
and hierarchical entities
right right it's a sample of
hierarchical answers good point
um all right we should rap here but but
let's come back with um
uh
um
um uh you know in a few days i guess
we'll because we're closing thirteen one
it would be nice to see an iteration of
these expression tree things
seem reasonable
yep
okay nice stuff alright thanks everybody
see you later